اذا 95 يوما من القتال المتواصل في قطاع
غزه لا تزال المقاومه الفلسطينيه قادره
على مفاجاه القوات الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
مستوطنين الاسرائيليين الى مستوطنات غلاف
غزه قبل وقف الحرب وقال بان وعودا نتنياهو
للمستوطنين بالعوده هي مجرد سراب هذا
يحيلنا الى مستوطنات غلاف قطاع غزه التي
تتشكل في او تتجمع في ثلاث تجمعات استيطان
هي اشكول وشعر ه نجف واشكل في المنطقه
الشماليه وهذه المستوطنات تمتد بهذا الشكل
الذي نشاهده على الخريطه ويسكن فيها
تقريبا
حوالي 50,000 مستوطن في هذه المنطقه كانوا
قد انسحبوا من هذه المنطقه وغادرونا
وتعدهم القوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
والحكومه الاسرائيليه بالعوده الى هذه
المنطقه التي يصل عمقها تقريبا الى 15 كيل
مترا ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم يعد اي من
هؤلاء وتهدد المقاومه الفلسطينيه بعدم
عوده هؤلاء بالاضافه الى ما قاله ابو حمزه
كان هناك مقاطع فيديو من خانيونس من
المنطقه الجنوبيه من قطاع غزه التي تشهد
قتالا عنيفا بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه من
جهه المتمثله في كتاب الق مسري القدس
والفصائل الاخرى وبين الجيش الاسرائيلي
المتوغلة
الشماليه الشرقيه وتتمركز الان في منطقه
البلديه في هذه النقطه تقريبا وهذه منطقه
المحطه التي تشهد قتالا عنيفا بين القوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المتوغلة
تحديد سرايا القدس قالت اليوم بانها ايضا
اسقطت طائره استطلاع اسرائيليه في سماء
خانيونس ضمن المعارك الجاريه في هذه
المنطقه اذا خانيونس تشهد معارك عنيفه
تقدم وتاخر لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ولكن عدم حسم المعركه مع معضله الانفاق
التي تحدثنا عنها كثيرا والتي يعاني منها
الجيش الاسرائيلي وفق بياناته ووفق
تحليلات عسكريه لصحف ووسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه اذا ما تحدثنا عن المنطقه
الشماليه او المنطقه الوسطى بدرجه درجه
اساسيه كان هناك اليوم حديث ويوم امس حديث
عن انفجار سياره محمله بالمتفجرات في
منطقه البريج منطقه البريج في وسط قطاع
غزه التي يحاول الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
السيطر عليها والضغط عليها بشكل كبير
المنطقه الشرقيه والمنطقه الشماليه مخيم
البريج هذا الذي نشاهده على الشاشه مخيم
صغير للغايه عرضه حوالي كيلو و200 متر
وطوله حوالي كيلو و200 متر ايضا مربع صغير
سكني كثيف بالسكان يضغط الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بشكل كبير بكثافه ناريه عاليه
على هذه المنطقه للسيطره عليها ولكن حتى ه
اللحظه لم يستطع السيطره على مخيم البريج
وهناك مقاومه شرسه الذي حدث خلال الساعات
الماضيه ان شاحنه محمله بالمتفجرات لقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي انفجرت في هذه
المنطقه روايه اسرائيليه نقلا عن وسائل
الاعلام اسرائيليه تقول بان دبابه
اسرائيليه ضربت هذه الشاحن المحمل
المتفجرات وسقط سته جنود وضباط وجرح اكثر
من 30 في هذه الحادثه المثيره للربع ولكن
حتى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد اي مصادر اخرى او
بيانات اخرى رسميه من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي او من قبل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
عن هذا الحدث المهم في منطقه البريج مع
الكثافه الناريه العاليه التي تركزها قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على المنطقه الوسطى
لانها تحاول السيطره وقطع الطريق كما فعلت
من وادي في المنطقه الشماليه تحاول فعل
الامر نفسه في المنطقه الجنوبيه وقطع هذه
المنطقه الوسطى عن محافظه دير البلح اذا
ما ذهبنا الى المنطقه الشماليه والحدث
الابرز كان مقطع الفيديو الذي نشرته كتائب
القسام من منطقه حي الزيتون احد او اكبر
احياء مدينه غزه في المنطقه الجنوبيه من
مدينه غزه كما نشاهد على الشاشه هذا الحي
الكبير شهد اليوم عمليات مقاومه شرسه كما
نشرت كتائب القسام كمائن مركبه للكتائب في
هذه المنطقه حي كما نشاهد على الشاشه هو
حي زراعي اصلا سمي بحي الزيتون لكثره
اشجار الزيتون في هذه المنطقه وهو ايضا
هذا الحي يحده بهذه شكل جحر الديك والمغر
والزهراء في المنطقه الجنوبيه
والجنوبيه الجنوبيه والجنوبيه الشرقيه جحر
الديك كما نشاهد الزهراء المغرا وجحر
الديك المنطقه الشماليه تل الهواء والصبره
ومدينه غزه البلده القديمه من مدينه غزه
كما نشاهد بهذا الشكل وايضا حي الشجاعيه
اذا هذا الحي الكبير الذي نشاهده على
الشاشه حي الزيتون احد اكبر او اكبر احياء
مدينه غزه يشهد قتالا عنيفا رغم ان قوات
الاحتلال توغلت فيه منذ الابي الاولى او
الايام الاولى للتوغل البري اصلا كانت
هناك اولى عمليات التوغل كانت في منطقه
جحر الديك والزيتون والمنطقه الشماليه
الغربيه والمنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه من
مدينه غزه اذا نحن نتحدث عن اسابيع واشهر
حوالي شهرين حتى هذه اللحظه من التواجد
العسكري الاسرائيلي في منطقه حي الزيتون
لا تزال المقاومه الفلسطينيه قادره على
الخروج في هذا الهي ضرب قوات الاحتلال
تشكيل كمائن مركبه والعوده عبر الانفاق
تصوير هذه مقاطع الفيديو ونشرها بكل سهوله
ويسر كما شاهدنا في مقاطع الفيديو اذا لا
تزال المقاومه الفلسطينيه كما يبدو من
مقطع الفيديو الذي نشرته كتاب قسام اليوم
انها قادره على التحرك بحريه كبيره
والقياده والسيطره في منطقه حي الزيتون
رغم التواجد العسكري الاسرائيلي الكثيف
بريا في هذه المنطقه منطقه حي الزيتون
المنطقه الفارغه تقريبا نسبيا التي تشهد
مساحات واسعه من المناطق الزراعيه ولكن
المقاومه الفلسطينيه رغم ان هذه المنطقه
مكشوفه للطيران طيران الاستطلاع والاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه المتواجد بكثافه الى
ان المقاومه فلينيه لا تزال قادره على
الخروج ونصب الكماءن وضرب القوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي المتواجده في هذه المنطقه مع
ايضا اشتباكات في المنطقه الشماليه من
مدينه غزه هكذا يبدو المشهد بشكل عام في
اليوم ال95 للقتال المتواصل في قطاع غزه